hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now i'm coming to
you from the interval here in san
francisco
where i will be joined by our speaker
tonight jason tester
to watch the pre-recorded version of his
talk along with answering questions from
you all afterwards
jason is a foresight researcher with the
institute for the future here in san
francisco
and has recently been exploring where
futurism sexual orientation and identity
meet
tonight he is going to give us a taste
of that research and show us how looking
at the future through an lgbtq lens can
help benefit
us all welcome jason tester
thank you xander thank you for all for
having me here at long now
um as andrew said i am jason and i'm on
a 20-year journey to make sense of my
queerness which has been a part of my
life for about that long i've also been
a professional futurist for about the
same amount of time 20 years
and to prove it to you here's an aged
image of what it might look like at age
60.
now i've long suspected that these two
halves of my life weren't a coincidence
and i think i've now discovered why and
i'm excited to really share that with
you tonight
i'm trusting most of the long now
audience will know the basic terms of
sexual orientation and gender identity
that i'll be using today but i do want
to define the word queer
because we really can't start talking
about it until i do so what is queer
well as an adjective queer describes all
the sexual and gender identities other
than straight and cisgender
so lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
people may all identify with the word
queer
queer is sometimes used to express that
sexuality and gender can be complicated
can change over time and might not fit
neatly into either or identities like
male or female
gay or straight so when i say quit the
future i mean in two ways and this first
way is based around queer the adjective
and that's i want to identify the future
forces that will disproportionately
disrupt
the lives of lgbtq people over the next
20 to 30 years
i want to center our lives in foresight
research and futures narratives
and especially to imagine interventions
to at least rebalance these imbalance
impacts as one example of a foresight
question i'm working with
how will caregiving assistance and aging
and place technologies deal with lgbtq
people in their relationships
it won't come as a shock to learn that
lgbt elders are much more likely to have
not had children
up to three to four times more likely
but even today
20 of lgbt older adults say they have no
one to call
in a time of crisis that is ten times
the general elderly population
and a mere eight percent of senior
housing centers offer services targeted
at lgbt older adults we're already deep
in a caregiving crisis between supply
and need
it's likely that lgbtq people will need
technologies of care
more than any other demographic another
question i'm exploring
is will ai and other intelligence
systems built with cisgender
heterosexual training data
constantly reinforce the gender binary
imagine bathrooms in the future
particularly in conservative areas or
regions of the world
equipped with vision recognition that
scan for biological markers
or stereotypical gender expressions
before they would actually admit someone
it's not hard to imagine a future where
more of us are living as gender fluid
while surrounded by by binary bias
machine intelligence programmed without
any exposure to other expressions or
experiences of gender
and last but not least there's the big
stuff that will affect us all
a study that came out last may
discovered that in a business's
usual climate scenario in the absence of
migration
one-third of the global population is
projected to experience a mean
annual temperature of greater than or
equal to 29 degrees celsius and that's
about 84 degrees fahrenheit
which is currently only found in about
8.8 of the earth's land surface and
that's mostly concentrated in the sahara
so the report goes on to say
specifically 3.5 billion people will be
exposed to a mean annual temperature of
greater than or equal to 29 degrees
celsius
living in a sahara-like climate i've
read that and that's a shocking
statistic it's truly hard to comprehend
but since i've been doing this work i
now take 10 of these impossibly large
numbers
to understand the impact on people who
are likely to identify in the coming
decades as queer
or not totally heterosexual so we take
that same sentence and we querify it
and we get specifically 350 million
queer people will be exposed to mean
annual temperatures
greater than or equal to 29 degrees
celsius now
3.5 billion people living in a
sahara-like climate is likely to yield
severe constraints of vital resources
and overall miserable
conditions but now imagine being queer
transgender
living in this newly inhospitable
climate that's located in a region of
the planet that's already inhospitable
to your very existence life in that in
that scenario sounds pretty hellish
another report last year was projected
that up to 1.2 billion people could be
displaced
by climate change by 2050 by mid-century
now i think applying the same queer math
that's the same headline reads
climate crisis could displace 120
million queer people
now my goal when i query these numbers
isn't to advocate for my people at the
expense of other groups
or to create an us versus them mentality
but it's simply to call out that large
areas of the planet are rapidly becoming
doubly inhospitable to queer lives who
should have equal rights
to the human universals of love
happiness and true expression
in the coming decades we are likely to
face mass migration at nearly
unimaginable levels
but also unprecedented research scarcity
and triage
and ultimately an inability to provide
the necessities of life for everyone
that needs them
so here are a couple of couple concrete
examples of this
according to the u.n 5 billion people
could have poor access to fresh water by
2050
and as early as 2030 global water demand
is expected to outstrip supply by 40
and lastly the u.n estimates that the
planet will need twice as much food in
2050 as it does today
while grain yields decline as
temperatures increase
now i know that these aren't uniquely
lgbtq issues
but they're likely to disproportionately
affect queer people given current
statistical realities
like this 27 of lgbt adults
experienced food insecurity in the prior
year compared to only 17
of non-lgbt adults and 22 percent of u.s
of lgbt people in the u.s live in
poverty compared to only 16 percent
so given these disproportionate
statistical realities today
it's very likely that they'll be they
will extend into the future and we'll
see these same
disproportionate impacts going forward
so if distribution of critical resources
is already this out of balance when we
don't when we when we have plenty of
food and water to go around today
imagine a world where we don't i hope
lgbtq people will fare equally
but i truly fear we won't the purpose of
my life has now become if we are indeed
all going extinct
let's go extinct together as equals
which brings me to my the first thesis
of queering the future
and i believe that we as a queer and
allied community have one generation
roughly 20 to 30 years
to achieve a basic floor of lgbtq
respect and dignity across the planet
before things get truly unambiguously
critically dire for billions of people
and this must be a widespread lived
reality found in the majority of hearts
and minds of a culture
not just toothless legislative
proclamations i mean not just
would you let your bisexual neighbor
borrow some of your water rations for
her family
would you offer your trans customer
shelter from the heat or your gaydis and
cousin a seat in your raft
unfortunately that scenario of mass
acceptance seems unlikely in the
relatively short timeframe demanded of
it
and a scary prospect for hundreds of
millions of lgbtq adults
and young adults if you don't achieve it
but perpetually looming right around the
corner is another potential
existential threat to my people last
year the largest study of the biology of
homosexuality was conducted
using genetic data from 23andme and the
uk biobank so about 500 000 participants
total their conclusion was
that some genes can account for about
one-third of the influence
over whether someone has ever had
same-sex sex at least once in their
lives
but not all geneticists supported this
research many in the lgbt affinity group
of the very institute leading this study
were opposed including a colleague of
the research leader who said
in part i have yet to see a compelling
argument that the potential benefits of
this study outweigh is potential harms
and indeed every year and i've been
studying the biology of sexuality for
years
there are new groundbreaking studies
there are also ongoing investigations
into epigenetic mechanisms of sexuality
and a potential connection to hormonal
conditions in the womb
we're doing a decen if slow job at
banning so-called gay
cures now these are deeply harmful
psychological treatments
passing off as beneficial therapies but
what if a gay vaccine became possible
cheaply at scale available for everyone
i'll grant you this is a wild card
scenario low probability but
speaking as a queer man myself very
extremely high impact
but please keep watching after i say
this but i cannot totally dismiss the
notion that a gay
vaccine would be all bad it might offer
the potential to eliminate the suffering
of hundreds of millions of lgbtq people
not yet born
especially in regions that are likely to
become inhospitable to queerness
and which happen to be those regions
becoming literally inhospitable to
humanity itself
to be clear it wasn't lost on me that i
might be turning into a queer man
considering eugenics against his own
people
but i am deeply afraid for our future
between the prospect of a century of
triaging water and food
for hundreds of millions of queer people
while seeming closer than ever to true
understanding of the biology of
homosexuality
i'll admit that these are deep-seated
existential fears
but i also need to flip that fear which
leads me to my second meaning
of queer of the future queer can also be
used as a verb and this definition is
proposed by charlie glickman
as he proposed fundamentally querying is
an active ongoing transformation
both within ourselves and in relation to
the world around us to queer something
is to take a look at its foundations and
question them
we can explore its limits its biases its
boundaries we can look for places where
there is elasticity
or discover ways where we can transform
it into something new
to queries to examine our assumptions
and decide which of them we want to keep
change discard or play with so i started
asking
does queerness confer any sort of
advantage especially for the wild future
world we're headed towards
what even is queerness beyond the theory
that we help the tribe raise kids
despite or maybe because of all the
trauma and marginalization that can come
from being born queer
and any family in any city in any
country in the world have we created
something in our culture found in the
periphery
and underground that has been waiting
for this moment what if queer culture
itself
with someone with some surprising human
universals across the globe
is itself a cultural evolutionary
mutation ready to confer advantages of
survival and resilience in the
larger population the core irony of
course
that these traits are sourced from a
group of people who cannot reproduce
themselves
but may be able to help humanity as a
whole adapt and thrive into the future
which leads me to thesis number two and
that's that the queer perspective is
made up of some surprisingly shared
traits and tendencies
that will be useful for societies and
people to thrive in the coming decades
ahead
put another way queerness can keep
things cool in hotter futures
today i've identified five traits that
can answer both of these questions
what is queerness and what mindsets and
practices will confer success
in the future we're likely headed
towards a queer future could be more
than it is today
more transformative more equitable hell
even more fabulous for everyone with a
touch of a queer eye
or maybe it's actually the future itself
that's already becoming more queer
and all of us need to play catch-up i
can be your guide like
virgil in the inferno or the mc from
cabaret
or any one of the hosts from queer eye
all rolled into one
of course queerness is more than these
five traits and success in the future
will require more skills than
this list but i hope seeing queerness in
the future in conversation together like
this
spark some novel insights for about how
you approach the future the lenses and
biases that we all bring to our
forecasting
so think of this as a guide to how to
queer the future
and step number one is to question
prevailing systems
queerness fundamentally exists in
opposition to arguably the most
prevailing system in the human condition
which is heterosexual reproduction
in fact the dna of queerness is
suspicion or outright rejection of norms
orthodoxy and continuation scenarios
because norms and continuation typically
kept us miserable or dead
for millennia a default to question the
unquestionable is a strong foundation
to readily envision transformative
alternatives and original ways of doing
and being
jose esteban munoz wrote cruising utopia
just as the light at the end of the
tunnel was shining
towards the the end of the aids epidemic
and we could begin to see queerness
again
for for its positivity and for its
hopefulness
and he wrote queerness is essentially
about the rejection of a here
now and on potentiality or concrete
possibility
for another world and this is an
infamous pamphlet that was passed out
by act up in the 1990 new york a pride
parade
being queer means leading a different
sort of life it's not about the
mainstream prophet margins patriotism
patriarchy or being assimilated
it's not about executive directors
privilege and elitism it's about being
on the margins
defining ourselves well many of us first
heard of
prison and police abolition this summer
with many of the black lives matter
riots
um resisting and questioning the
dominant systems of
of police and incarceration in the
cultural state have long been in the dna
of queerness itself
going all the way back to the 1966
compton's cafeteria riots here in san
francisco
or three years later uh at the root of
the stonewall riots which was an
anti-police demonstration
and as noted activist dr angela davis
has pointed out as
is true for so much of queer history it
was transgender people who actually
pointed the way
to this resistance dr davis says we
support the trans community precisely
because the trans community has taught
us
how to challenge that which is totally
accepted as normal if it is possible to
challenge the gender binary
we can certainly effectively resist
prisons and police
now coming out is also a form of
questioning the prevailing systems
by choosing to come out queer people go
through a process they start a personal
journey that consciously places them
on the margins of what is quantitatively
mainstream and that comes with a
double-edged sword
you no longer have an autopilot the same
as many of your straight heterosexual
friends do
and rather than being superfluous to
change the margins are in fact
the foundry of the future where
societies innovate and grow
so they're very active coming out the
very act of declaring yourself a queer
person
is itself questioning the mainstream
system and starting to make the future
in a new way
our second step in how to query the
future is about rejecting binaries and
binary thinking most forecasts of work
and life in the future
imagine greater fluidity in our
identities our preferences
self-expression and our communications
and interactions
but queerness found comfort with nuance
outside of categories early on
simply because we've been forced to
craft our own alternatives to most
institutions in society
queer adaptations to the binaries of
married or single or family or friend
or even our own internal compasses of
attraction and gender in each moment
often begin like all novel futures as
outliers if not considered fully deviant
then certainly not accepted by the
mainstream
before time passes they're reconsidered
for their benefits and suddenly have
widespread appeal
let's say let's take the gender binary
for example the gender binary is so
entrenched in our lives
that we will literally explode the world
to reinforce it
these are scenes from gender binary real
parties over the past year in which
couples dramatically reveal the gender
of their child
through a pink or blue substance such as
exploding smoke
the binary is so reinforced that so many
couples have taken this to an extreme
with their reveals
inadvertently lighting tens of thousands
of acres on fire
now that biology does not equal identity
often gets lost in the spectacle
binary defi binary defenders have
crashed planes
enlisted alligators backfired trucks and
gotten into fights at and kicked out of
applebee's
and most unfortunately once exploded a
pipe bomb into a guest's skull
killing her instantly as the atlantic
put it
how many people have to die before we're
done with gender reveals and i would ask
with gender itself
another example of resisting binaries uh
comes from us from
sex columnist dan savage and his term
that he coined
about 10 years ago called monogamish and
he coined this term to describe the
arrangement that he has with his husband
for
occasional extramarital sex with other
people and the rules and
the requirements that go with that
condition savage was aiming to create a
more realistic sexual ethic that would
prize honesty a little
flexibility and unnecessary forgiveness
something to live between promiscuity
and monogamy which savage considers
right for many but unnatural for most
and and so again another queer
adaptation to
uh true to a heteronormative binary
i could have put up many headlines here
to show
just how queer the younger generations
are proving to be
than their older counterparts teens
these days are queer
af studies says only 48 of gen z's
identify as exclusively heterosexual
compared to 65 of millennials age 21 to
34.
those belonging to generation z also
rejected the gender binary while
shopping
only 44 said they always bought clothes
designed for their own gender
versus 54 of millennials so
as we can see the gender binary at least
with these new younger generations
is falling fast our next step in our
journey to how to query the future
is connect intersectionally now this
really starts from an
assumption that a more egalitarian and
broadly prosperous future
seems difficult to achieve if we can't
agree to live and interact
in both deep diversity and deep harmony
with each other
as simple as it sounds working at
widespread scale to acknowledge and
understand that the living experiences
of people from different backgrounds
will be different is a very hard notion
for many people to truly grasp
including others experiences of
discrimination and privilege
particularly realities of people of
color
but also the lives of those with
disabilities and people with fewer means
than ourselves
this content is known as
intersectionality while relatively
simple to convey
and can be very difficult to put into
practice but without this basic floor of
mutual respect and acceptance we may not
survive
intersectionality is arguably the most
important skill for us making it into
the future
if so many of our most talented
community members hold back from their
true selves
their full creativity their full joy and
passion from the
from the unprecedented task we face
remaking the world because the fullness
of their identities feels unwelcome
we do not get all of the ideas that we
need to make it into the next world
this is where i have to be the first to
admit that queerness and particularly
white queerness
is far from perfect at making this
future our reality the first super gay
rights groups
formed after stonewall were deeply
intersectional and multiracial
and many argue that the recent focus on
gay marriage took us away from the more
important issues of economic and
employment equity
as one signal that the queer community
is trying to require its own future
we've amended the pride flag to
acknowledge and center the lives
and importance of queer people of color
in our movement adding black and brown
stripes on top of the already seven
color rainbow
one way in which queer people as a
community do have an advantage is
through the shared advantage of
marginalization
one experience of marginalization
predisposes you to under a greater
understanding
of compound marginalizations that other
people may face
one way to think about intersectionality
as it is as a tool for augmented empathy
empathy of course will be a vital skill
in this increasingly crowded
automated and unequal polarized and
mediated centuries so far
understanding the way another person
encounters the world accepted or shunned
by their peers bosses and strangers
is a deeply human act now as we're
talking about practicing
intersectionally i want to make a bit of
a side note here to say that i firmly
believe that the future of the future
is being created by transgender women of
color and gender non-binary people of
color
and that we should all trust their
leadership particularly those those of
us in the queer community
i can't highly recommend enough the
documentary the future of trans by amara
jones
and the trans agenda for liberation's
call to action to grow your
understanding of their deeply
intersectional lives
additionally the exciting intersectional
futurism of people like lonnie brooks
who's pioneering afro career futures and
who's long now talk you can easily
google and watch
our next step in how to query the future
is one very much related to
some fundamentals of queerness embracing
pleasure and joy
historically queerness has long
prioritized feelings of pleasure and joy
as indicators
of happiness and well-being far far
before modern medicine
accepted their value but not just
medicinally
queerness has spoken of these as
essential precursors
to unspeakable heights of creativity and
uninhibited ideation
basically from foundations to imagining
radically new futures but even this had
become taboo since queer pleasure queer
pleasure was deeply stigmatized when
lgbtq people were fighting battles on
multiple fronts
against aids and for equal equal access
to mainstream institutions like the
right to marry and adopt the fundamental
sexuality of queerness
went away to for many people to fight
respect
find respectability in the mainstream
society
but this is starting to come back in in
movements like pleasure activism
pleasure activism is the organized
struggle to re-prioritize bliss
and sensuality to build individual and
collective resilience
and ultimately as a necessary foundation
to conjure better worlds
i'd like to share this quote from
pleasure activism author adrienne marie
brown
you're not going to forget the suffering
in the world just because you had a
great orgasm
you're going to have more resilience for
turning and facing that suffering
if you're also in touch with the part of
your life that feels amazing and not
just the total catastrophes that are
happening
or as our favorite queer futurist of all
time jose esteban munoz put it in
cruising utopia
some will say that all we have are the
pleasures of this moment but we must
never settle for that minimal transport
we must dream and enact new and better
pleasures other ways of being in the
world and ultimately new worlds
which this quote really fascinates me as
someone who is always trying to come up
with new ideas and new
and new transformative more accurate
futures more wild futures
that what if we actually based what
based that not on technology not on
pro on gdp not on value but on pleasure
and really our goal was to find new
pleasure in new
and new futures that really excites me
and our last step in how to create a
future is
hustling between worlds so for a long
time
to find companionship and work with
neither were available to us in
mainstream society queer folks for
millennia
have been re perceiving and repurposing
spaces and platforms
to seek their hidden layers latent gigs
and the underground social networks
when any form of traitor hustling
existed on the margins of respectable
society
queerness pioneered this this rhythm of
finding ad hoc latent opportunity
the hustle that now truly defines the
future
work for food love everything on demand
if you know where and how to look
only recently has proficiency of the
hustle and juggling multiple hustles
become an admired ability
by now you've heard of used or as you're
watching me are also getting
notifications
from a location-based smartphone app but
grindr for gay men started it all
launched less than two years after the
iphone grinder was an instantly
game-changing tool for the hustle
and changed the future of online dating
rather than congregating in bars to find
romance and limited by who else happened
to be there
grinder gave you the superpower to stay
home and see the previously invisible
layer of other guys near you
grandeur didn't invent mobile social
networking but it certainly did set an
early model for how we come to see our
think of our phones
as secret decoders revealing the latent
possibilities surrounding us
for everything from car rental to food
delivery to romance
futurist madeline ashby who has done a
great deal of
speculative work and recently wrote how
to future
um has this passage that i love that
captures a lot about the
relationships between hustling in the
future she writes for a long time the
future has belonged to people who have
not had to struggle
and i think that will still be true but
as more and more systems collapse
currency energy the ability to get water
to the ability to work
the future will increasingly belong to
those who know how to hustle
and those people are not the people who
are producing those purely optimistic
futures
the future belongs to those who know how
to hustle and mj patrony
a local queer futurist and ux designer
in an interview he talked about what he
values looking for in queer employees
we often look for people who have
existed in lots of different worlds
and walking back and forth between these
spaces and never being fully at home
they learn a lot about the unspoken
rules and assumptions and codes and
values that exist
so i really want to try to answer the
question in these five trades
how can querying the future solve our
most we get problems how can querying
the future
help anybody and i hope that across
these five skills of traits that show
that
queer folks across countries and
millennia have demonstrated a nimble
resilience
prosperity for adaptation and
resourcefulness a
healthy skepticism and embrace for other
worlds a continual if far from perfect
practice of deep
empathy that keeps us striving to do
better
and a widespread acceptance of the
connection between our biologies
and our desires and achieving our
destinies under any conditions
but on an even deeper level we won't
achieve transformative solutions to our
most critical problems
using the same legacy tools that we've
used in the past
we need everyone to bring their ideas
and engagement to bear on the complexity
complexity of the future yet 1.5 billion
people currently live in 72 countries
where homosexuality is illegal
and billions more live in countries
without widespread cultural acceptance
and we know that being your full self
makes a difference in your participation
and your citizenship in a
society or in a workplace as one example
the boston consulting group has found
that the ability to be out at work
helps workers feel twice as much
psychological safety and one and a half
times more
empowered and free to take creative
risks
imagine imagine imagine the other
freedoms that billions of people
lose being in the closet around the
world every single day
but setting aside productivity or
innovation on any measure
i want to end on this statistic which i
learned
last year and has really become one of
my north stars
researchers at the family acceptance
project at san francisco state
university
one question they're asked is do you
believe that you will ever be
a happy lgbt adult for queer youth who
come from families rated extremely
accepting
92 percent 92 are able to imagine
themselves in happy futures
for queer youth from families who who
outright shun
or reject them only 35 have this ability
think about that for a minute two-thirds
of lgbtq young people
who had the misfortune to be born to
families that cannot accept them
have lost the ability to imagine their
future selves being happy
i can't see how losing that ability is
any different from losing one's
fundamental sense of hope
hope for themselves hope for the world
hope for their for
their individual future or ours
collectively so it's phenomenal like
this
that happened every day anywhere an
lgbtq kid is growing up
knowing that they're different afraid to
express it even in the most progressive
regions let alone the most conservative
that motivates me to keep queering the
future and showing that the future can
be queer
to create more scenarios with thriving
queer protagonists to uncover the trends
that will particularly impact lgbtq
people
not just to preempt emerging victimhood
but also to empower them to grab the
wheel
and grab us by the future they see and
deserve
to learn more about any of the lgbt
foresight research that i presented
today please check out the research home
at queerthefuture.org
this has been me so far with the help of
a lot of friends and experts and
and people have smarter people i'm
talking to but i would love this to be a
home where anyone
anyone who identifies as a queer future
as a trans future so not a non-binary
futurist
anywhere in the world can come and can
share their ideas and we can create
collective visions for how we want our
lives and our communities to live
in the future thank you very much
[Music]
you